welcome back okay
I had a typo in my last my last
description of this granion the the
thing I missed was that this is a hat
complex conjugate transpose which means
that this T inverse a star T star should
actually be plus let's just actually
work this out I have this matrix that's
a hat okay a hat
so a hat star let's just do a transpose
is T star a star T inverse star okay so
if I have a product of these matrices
and I want to transpose that product I
literally just flip the order and
transpose each of them so the transpose
of this is T star times a star times T
inverse star that's this thing so that's
what I messed up this should have a t
star a star t- star okay this is a nasty
ugly math so now instead of this being a
T inverse this is supposed to be a T
star and instead of this being a T
inverse it's a - star okay these guys
actually do cancel T inverse star times
T star is the identity matrix so this
cancels and what I'm left with is T
inverse WC t inverse complex conjugate
transpose this sounds super complicated
this is what WC hat equals at the end of
the day these are all things you can
actually compute in MATLAB in one line
this is in the inverse you can compute
an inverse you can compute an inverse
and then transpose transpose is just
apostrophe okay so it's really easy to
actually compute these it's fancy math
notation but this is just the inverse of
T and then transpose it and so this is
how how the Grampians transform and I
think this is also right for the the
observability cranium so you can go back
and just kind of work through all of
this super carefully on a clean sheet of
paper and convince yourself that this is
how
graeme ins transform your
controllability transforms like this
your observability cramming transforms
like this and then we're going to use
that property to design a good tee that
balances controllability and
observability thank you